so my question for you is I am on baby
step number six I'm single with no
children and I'm at the point where I
would like to get will and Trust set up
so that if anything happens to me before
I grow my family my assets can go to my
extended family and not to the
government angel with that being said I
have my parents as the primary
beneficiaries for now my hope is that I
outlive them but in the case that I
don't hold into the primary in the event
that they pass I need to pick a
secondary beneficiary I have one brother
two stepbrother and stepsister and one
niece with that being said I'm a little
conflicted on what to do for my
secondary beneficiary because I feel
that not all of my siblings would
cherish the money responsibly I don't
want to create conflict by you know only
giving it to some of my siblings but at
the same time I really wouldn't want to
see the asset squandered yeah how old
are you I'm 33 okay you're being very
very wise congratulations you're under
no moral or spiritual obligation to
treat everyone equally no one in this
world is treated equally
I get discriminated against because I'm
bald
no one is treated equally some people
work harder than others some are smarter
than others some are prettier than
others and their incomes and the money
that they end up managing are therefore
different I cannot throw a football like
Peyton Manning or Tom Brady so I don't
get their paycheck and so that's how
that's but that's the point point is
we're always going to have wealth
inequality you can't fix that fair is
what's at the county there is no fair
and so the what's fair is
someone that works twice as much ought
to make twice as much that's fair it
shouldn't be equal socialism is not fair
and so when you're looking at your will
if you kind of go through that lens then
you say I do not have to do this I'll
give you an example in the Ramsey
household okay
we're people of faith and so we believe
we don't own the money that we're
managing it for God and if you are not
walking with God you are not eligible to
manage God's stuff and so if one of mine
goes off the ranch and decides they're
gonna be a heroin addict or run around
with in some kind of crazy wicked
lifestyle or something they're not in
the will and it's not punishment it's
because they're not eligible to be a
steward of God's things when they're not
one of his children and so that's how we
view it and by the way we've
communicated that pretty clearly and so
you what you get when you get our stuff
is you get the responsibility of
managing it it's not that you hit the
lottery and so that's how we've
communicated our stuff in our estate
plan with our heirs and so you know at
33 years old if you're in good health I
don't know that you have to stir the pot
necessarily like I would as a 60 year
old dad I need to start the pot a little
more and let everybody know exactly how
I feel but I want to set you free from
if you've got one of these siblings or
half siblings that is misbehaving in
their life you don't want to fund their
misbehavior that is not an act of love
when you give a heroin addict a million
dollars you'll kill them because they'll
kill themselves with that money and so
when someone's operating with weakness
and character or weakness and behaviors
and you give them money you expand the
problem in the curse that is in their
life and so you don't want to hurt
someone you love and you will be hurting
someone who's misbehaving when you give
them money and so you're under no
obligation to give them anything nor are
you in there any obligation to do it
evenly and so I would just set it up
today the way it is and by the way the
good news about beneficiaries and heirs
and wills nothing's permanent until you
die so you can change it every year
maybe one of them gets all better and
got a hole clean life and they clean up
their act and well we you know that'd be
wonderful not mad at people
I just want to bless them when you give
people money that are misbehaving it is
not a blessing it's a curse